[Música]
faltou o que faz um estado desenvolvido
grandes reservas de petróleo grandes
reservas de minério que grandes áreas
agricultáveis ou pecuária
acho que não se fosse isso certamente
santa catarina não seria um dos estados
mais desenvolvidos do país
eu tenho uma teoria e para contar pra
vocês eu vou contar um pouco de uma
história de uma cidade chamada pausa pra
quem não conhece
imagine uma cidade com pouco mais de 170
mil habitantes é uma cidade que nos
últimos dez anos experimentou um
crescimento muito acima da média na
maioria das cidades brasileiras
impulsionada principalmente pela
construção civil
mas esse crescimento não se transformou
em melhores condições de vida para as
pessoas
ou seja a cidade crescia mas não se
desenvolver
ainda hoje o município apesar desse
crescimento dos últimos anos apresenta
dados bem antagônicos
por exemplo o município ocupa o 10º
lugar no ranking das maiores economias
do estado mas ocupa o 79º lugar no
ranking do idh
se por um lado com o município é o que
mais cresceu na região da grande
florianópolis por outro possui a menor
renda média de todos os municípios da
região a maior favela do estado fica em
palhoça
lá vivem cerca de 6 mil pessoas 60%
dessas pessoas vivem com menos de um
salário mínimo e 50 famílias não possuem
renda nenhuma
esse foi o cenário que encontrei quando
cheguei na cidade para assumir a
secretaria do desenvolvimento econômico
sustentável do município
cheguei à conclusão então que para
garantir que a cidade continuasse
crescendo e que esse crescimento se
transformasse em melhores condições de
vida para as pessoas
era fundamental mudar o eixo econômico
do município
falei fazer com que ele se mover se de
uma economia intensiva em mão de obra
para uma economia intensiva em
conhecimento e inovação
por três motivos primeiro porque no
mundo atual o que gera riqueza
verdadeiramente é o conhecimento ea
inovação
uma pesquisa da global enterpreneurship
monitor por exemplo revela que
empreendimentos intensivos em inovação e
conhecimento geram muito mais riqueza do
que empreendimentos da chamada velha
economia empreendimentos intensivos em
conhecimento são o foco dos chamados
empreendedores por oportunidade
empreendedores são aquelas pessoas que
segundo joseph schumpeter impulsiona o
capitalismo gerando novos produtos novos
processos criando novos mercados e
métodos mais eficientes e mais
econômicos empreendedores por
oportunidade
são aquelas pessoas que decidiram
empreender
apesar de já possuir uma forma de
sustentar a família identificou uma
oportunidade no mercado e planejam muito
por isso a chance de um empreendimento
desta certo é sempre muito maior
empreendedor por necessidade por sua vez
é aquela pessoa que não tem mais como
sustentar a família
normalmente desempregado acaba pegando
suas últimas reservas para colocar um
negócio 50% desses empreendedores por
necessidade vão fechar as portas antes
de completarem três anos
a mesma pesquisa da gem aponta que
enquanto no brasil 55% dos
empreendedores são motiva são motivados
por oportunidade
nos estados unidos esse número é de 80%
para se ter uma idéia da capacidade de
gerar riqueza de uma economia intensiva
em conhecimento e inovação
basta dizer que 95 por cento da riqueza
povos estados unidos foi gerada por uma
nos últimos 40 anos por uma legião de
empreendedores por oportunidade de onde
surgiram ícones do capitalismo moderno
como apple google facebook
o software a propósito só para vocês
saberem o valor de mercado da apple e da
microsoft juntas é praticamente o pib do
brasil
a segunda razão para apostar nessa
mudança do eixo econômico está
relacionado com o custo da produção do
financiamento da produção no brasil
economias intensivas em mão-de-obra
necessitam de grandes valores e volumes
de dinheiro para o financiamento da sua
produção como brasileiro poupa muito
pouco o custo do financiamento no brasil
é muito caro
isso significa que nem bem uma
matéria-prima entrou na linha de
produção de uma empresa brasileira e já
somos menos competitivos do que qualquer
outro país do mundo
a terceira razão para apostar nessa
mudança do eixo econômico está
relacionado com uma característica do
povo catarinense
para contar essa característica pra
vocês
para ilustrar essa característica pra
vocês eu vou contar a história de uma
grande empresa catarinense chamada
consul
quem de vocês aqui tem um
eletrodoméstico da consul em casa por
acaso vocês sabem porque o nome da
consulta com sul apresentou vou contar
pra vocês
essa história começa na década de 50 com
o empreendedor chamado vitte freitag e
seus dois sócios rudolf e guilherme
nessa época geladeira um artigo de luxo
só pessoas muito ricas se uma rua do
filho guilherme tinha uma oficina que
consertava de tudo um dia chegou uma
geladeira querosene para eles
consertarem juntos convite frita ele
resolveu desmontar toda a geladeira e
chegaram à conclusão de que poderiam
eles próprios fabricar uma mas ele não
tinha dinheiro pra isso eles resolveram
então pedi dinheiro emprestado a um rico
empresário da região chamado cônsul
carlos rennó que era um grande
empresário do setor têxtil de brusque
o cônsul carlos renovou emprestou
dinheiro que eles precisavam em
homenagem eles colocaram o nome da
empresa de consumo
mas essa é a parte mais bonita dessa
história na década de 70 um dos
principais fornecedores de peças para
cônsul passava uma grave crise econômica
a alemanha e precisou suspender o
fornecimento de uma peça para uma série
de de clientes ea cônsul foi uma dessas
empresas escolhidas frente fria que não
tinha facebook não tinha desaprendido
então ele não podia ficar atrás de um
computador postando nas redes sociais ou
no site como reclame aqui
ele resolveu então pegar um avião e ir
até a alemanha
chegando lá a recepcionista da empresa
informou que como ele não havia marcado
horário e não seria atendido
a recepcionista certamente não conhecia
um legítimo descendente de alemães que
enfrentou tanta dificuldade para começar
uma vida longe de casa
como sou descendente de alemães meu
sobrenome fat significa banha
qualquer semelhança com o meu tipo
físico é mera coincidência
eu consigo ver vítima dizer para ela eu
não vou sair daqui enquanto não for
atendido
não vim lá do brasil aqui pra nada em
seguida vi tive uma um grupo de
engravatados caminhando pelo saguão do
hotel da empresa e deduziu que uma
daquelas pessoas era o dono da empresa
ele se dirigiu então aquele grupo e
perguntou qual deles era o dono da
empresa um se apresentou então 20
perguntou pra ele porque ele havia
determinado a suspensão do fornecimento
da peça o empresário alemão então
respondeu que em virtude da crise
econômica e precisou escolher alguns
clientes para deixar de fornecer ea
cônsul infelizmente tinha sido uma
dessas empresas
conta a história que evite falar então
virou pro alemão e respondeu pois que
você sabendo que durante a guerra lá em
santa catarina
milhares de nossas famílias tiravam do
que nós tínhamos para comer e para se
vestir para mandar para os atingidos da
guerra que na alemanha e agora você
condena essas mesmas pessoas suspendendo
fornecimento dessa peça que significa o
fim da empresa e de milhares de empregos
o alemão então se vira por um dos seus
sensores e determina eu gostaria que
nunca mais fosse suspenso o fornecimento
da peça para conz
essa história retrata bem o que eu quero
dizer para vocês sobre essa
característica do povo catarinense
somos empreendedores inovadores e
inquieto por natureza não ficamos
esperando a solução cair do céu
se fosse assim talvez nós estivéssemos
até hoje esperando ajuda vi depois da
enchente de 83 em blumenau
ao invés disso que esse povo fez
investiu na criação de uma festa para
ajudar na reconstrução da cidade que deu
tão certo que se tornou a segunda maior
festa da cultura alemã do mundo
essa então é característica que eu quero
dizer pra vocês somos um povo
empreendedor por natureza e essa é uma
característica que me deu coragem em
apostar na mudança do eixo econômico de
palhoça
voltemos então a palhoça
como fazer essa mudança do eixo
econômico no município o poder público
quando não atrapalha já faz muito mas
uma mudança como essa pode ser acelerada
quando o poder público faz mais do que
não atrapalhar quando ele resolve ser o
protagonista desse processo e como ele
pode fazer isso criando um ambiente
favorável de negócios para os
empreendedores inovadores em empresas
inovadoras são exponenciais saindo 0 a 1
milhão numa velocidade muito maior do
que a empresa dos setores tradicionais e
pagam salários muito maiores e isso é
exatamente o que eu queria papai noel
rosa
uma das coisas mais gratificantes se
trabalhar no serviço público é que você
pode efetivamente influenciar a vida das
pessoas
talvez nenhum outro lugar é possível
influenciar tanto a vida das pessoas
como um serviço público
o primeiro desafio então foi convencer o
prefeito fazer enxergar que só gerando
mais riqueza será possível ter dinheiro
para investimentos em áreas como saúde
educação segurança
e saneamento apresentei para ele o
diagnóstico
tínhamos uma cidade que crescia mas que
não se desenvolver um povo que traz no
empreendedorismo traz o empreendedorismo
na sua essência a necessidade de
estimular a destruição criativa de
schumpeter e um objetivo bem claro mudar
o eixo econômico do município e mais um
detalhe
tínhamos a pedra branca para quem não
conhece a pedra branca um bairro
planejado que é referência em urbanismo
sustentável no mundo
a pedra branca oferece a infraestrutura
condizente com o tipo de desenvolvimento
econômico que queríamos convencido o
prefeito identificamos os pilares
fundamentais do programa de
financiamento e incentivos econômicos a
atração de investimento e formação de
talentos
montamos o que era o protótipo do
programa que reúne um conjunto de
projetos de lei
o plano previa ainda um programa de
qualificação de empreendedores concursos
consultoria sou o workshop criamos uma
linha de crédito com juros subsidiados e
sem necessidade de garantia para os
empreendedores locais
montamos uma plataforma de atração de
investimentos com o objetivo de promover
a cidade como destino de investimentos e
facilitar a vida do investidor e por fim
iniciamos uma aproximação com as
universidades locais para garantir a
formação dos talentos necessários para o
sucesso do plano
temos esse plano o nome de nova palhoça
então reunimos os principais atores da
inovação no estado
para validar esse protótipo
especialmente a sua aderência às
demandas do mercado
se não houvesse interferência certamente
esse programa viraria mais um powerpoint
o plano trouxe uma série de inovações
sob o ponto de vista de políticas
públicas como por exemplo um fundo de
inovação que não depende de dotação
orçamentária
todos os fundos de inovação que
analisamos depende de votação
área o prefeito quando prepara o
orçamento do ano subseqüente
ele estabelece um valor para o fundo de
inovação como inovação nunca é
prioridade para os prefeitos quando o
orçamento previsto não se concretiza o
prefeito precisa contingenciar o
orçamento e acaba sempre contingenciando
os recursos do fundo de inovação
o nosso desafio então era como montar um
fundo de inovação que não depende de
dotação orçamentária e que portanto não
estiver sujeito aos contingenciamentos
outro programa dê nova palhoça bastante
inovador é o que prevê o financiamento
do capital de giro para as empresas
a partir da geração de imposto dessas
mesmas empresas
em pouco tempo esse plano começou a dar
sinais de que estaria dando resultado
inúmeras empresas começaram a se
transferir para o município
empresas extremamente inovadoras como
por exemplo uma empresa que produz
máquinas de marcação a lei z que foi a
empresa que segundo a consultoria
delloite mais cresceu no brasil entre os
anos de 2011 e 2014 cresceu incríveis
1.800 por cento
ou então a empresa que produz o primeiro
robô 100% brasileiro
ou ainda a empresa que é considerada a
maior indústria farmacêutica de
manipulação do mundo
essa empresa em apenas três meses de
funcionamento já se tornou uma das
maiores pagadoras de impostos do
município
o empreendedorismo também parece começar
a dar sinais de responder a estímulos
dessas políticas públicas em 2015
foram abertas mil e 500 novas empresas
no município
nossa incubadora já reúne mais de 30
empresas incubadas na pedra branca
já são mais de 500 ser pj os ativos que
faturaram juntos mais de 1 bilhão de
reais em uma região que até pouco tempo
atrás era apenas uma fazenda de criação
de gado se tornou e sim de algumas das
empresas mais
jogadoras do país colecionamos alguns
reconhecimentos em 2015
ficamos em sexto lugar no ranking da
connect smart cities que leva em
consideração a qualidade de políticas
públicas voltadas ao desenvolvimento
econômico
sei que uma mudança como essa leva um
tempo maior do que o tempo de mandato
certamente eu não vou estar mais na
secretaria do desenvolvimento econômico
quando este ciclo tiver concluído mas me
conforta saber em que de alguma forma
contribuir para estimular o
empreendedorismo inovador na cidade
ainda chega na porta da secretaria e me
deparo com cavalos na frente da porta da
secretaria
quando não tem que chutar los para poder
entrar na secretaria mas me conforta
saber que de alguma forma contribuir
para estimular esse empreendedorismo
inovador na cidade
então quando me perguntam o que faz um
estado desenvolvido
eu respondo a capacidade de sermos
empreendedores resilientes inovadores
sempre seja no serviço público ou na
iniciativa privada
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]